weekend ce weekend j'ai reçu les
bulletins des enfants
et qu'elle ne fut pas ma surprise
quand j'ai vu que mon fils suivait mon
chemin
le chemin de la médiocrité
[Rires]
au niveau de des courses et pour
l'instant on est en difficulté surtout
que les matières non il y a un problème
avec l'anglais tu as du mal à l'anglais
de faire un rap première langue sans
déconner
ma fille tu es très contente a lu les
encouragements
trop vite
ils sont 14 dans la classe
[Rires]
et mon fils il est 128 il est 26 donc
les gars est-ce qu'on appelle
l'antépénultième
pas vous êtes méchants
quelle est ma fierté
il a la meilleure note en sport
et ma fille a la meilleure note de la
classe en art 19 et demi
vous avez une artiste après après le
truc c'est que bon physique-chimie c'est
une énorme banane et à mon père là qui
est venu ce weekend la cargarde un peu
des bulletins est-ce que je l'aiderai
pas au physique
il arrive là
tu vois est-ce que je vais te répondre
physique-chimie la petite tu vois parce
qu'en physique-chimie moi j'étais une
énorme banane moi mon père il m'a fait
réviser la physique chimie frère ils
sont rigoler je me rappelle parce qu'il
rentrait il rentrait genre à 23h
travailleuse
et il avait le livre ah mon Dieu de bio
et de physique-chimie et il me lisait le
livre frère écoute-moi bien mais pas
j'étais fracasse mon frère mais c'est
quoi une parler de truc là en biologie
la mitose et tout je dis mais c'est toi
le mytho
j'ai compris tu as compris super super
c'est qu'elle à quelle heure demain le
contrôle 9h
je vais déchirer papa
une semaine après combien tu as eu en
bio 4
il m'a fait réviser sur la tête de ma
mère il m'a fait réviser
physique-chimie et bio pour le bac vous
savez comment j'ai eu non
je te jure c'est vrai
tu avais une belle réussite
justement en fait révé les jeunes en
quoi vous étiez fort parce que vous avez
une belle réussite
ils n'existent pas ces gars-là je disais
mais bien sûr j'ai inventé des livres
mon frère mais bien sûr comme disait DJ
zeitounis
dans l'Odyssée lunaire l'homme est un
chat pour l'homme
c'est pas un loupé
j'ai inventé des auteurs
l'oral du bac français je suis arrivé
j'ai eu 14 ans sur quel texte le texte
je vous l'avais dit j'ose pas le dire
mais j'ai triché moi au bac français
[Applaudissements]
c'est très grave franchement faut pas le
faire c'est horrible j'avais mon frère
j'avais une balise j'avais une Samsonite
avec moi frère une Samsonite frère une
lisbah comme ça parce que il y avait des
textes à apprendre
et j'avais un livre pour moi un livre
que tu donnes à la prof et j'avais un
troisième livre où j'avais tout marqué
dans les interstices vous savez ou pas
j'avais une meuf dans la classe Johanna
Benaim que j'embrasse très sympathique
mais bravo elle elle m'avait tout noté
dans les interstices c'est quelqu'un
d'autre parce qu'elle était gentille et
elle m'a dit elle m'a tout noté non non
c'est une super copine comme une j'ai
toujours une copine
elle m'a tout écrit frère et je veux
arriver mon frère maintenant j'avais 3
livres fois 14
j'avais 42 livres dans la valise frère
je suis arrivé moi je la traîné quand
même mais tu vas aujourd'hui
après l'examinatrice samedi euh aller au
fond de la classe préparez le texte
donne le texte j'arrive je sors mon
livre mes interstices trucs je copie
tout commence
après je sors l'autre livre vierge je
remets l'autre dedans et elle je lui
donne un livre vierge j'arrive Bam Bam
et après il y a un texte libre et là
j'ai un autre texte je me dis ouais je
vais vous interroger et là je dis ouais
mais bon là moi c'est moi je suis
certainement faire du théâtre
j'adore l'univers de Jean à nouilles
non mais j'ai sorti deux trois bails
comme as elle a dit oui c'est vrai vous
voulez faire du théâtre qu'on a parlé on
a parlé comme ça une demi-heure on a
fait des cadavres et tout elle m'a dit
c'est franchement je mets je vais vous
mettre une bonne note
une autre triche
j'ai pas triché à l'écrit un coup de
chance un coup de chance et puis après
j'ai eu des notes que vous connaissez
les drames qui ont jalonné et matériel
non mais c'est vrai et c'est pour ça que
tout le monde dit je suis sur les
audiences les audiences moi c'est comme
les notes comme j'ai toujours eu que des
notes pourries en vrai moi à chaque fois
que la prof elle est arrivée avec les
notes quand même vous savez quand les
notes la prof elle rentre elle dit allez
je vais rendre la meilleure à la toute
mauvaise note sur la tête de ma mère dès
le début je voyais ma feuille de passer
dans le bateau
je vais donner moi la mienne tout de
suite on a pas besoin après on va
attendre jusqu'à la fin frère c'est bon
on sait que c'est moi non mais sérieux
comme ça
pour la feuille et l'encre
sur ma douche
vous en ai déjà parlé Monsieur Le Goff
un prof frère écoute-moi bien il était
comme as et il faisait comme as et il
rendait les copies mais les
appréciations n'avaient rien à voir avec
ce qu'il disait moi il me l'a fait moi à
chaque fois qu'il en est par exemple
c'est nul ça tu fuis rien toi dis cette
[Rires]
Chartier c'est pas mal tu fais des
efforts de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
golf Monsieur Le Goff et moi
et sur la bonne voie c'est génial hein
[Applaudissements]
je me rappelle aussi j'avais un prof de
musique
[Rires]
il faut pas le faire j'étais j'avais
j'étais en 3D mais en fait j'avais un
livre un magazine un peu haute et à
chaque fois qu'il joue de la flûte parce
qu'il nous montre quand
même des photos porno
je sais pas
c'est vrai maintenant que nous jouons
quelque chose
à la fin tu vas faire la revue
et je te jure là monsieur Guillaume de
fou moi attends moi j'avais raconté ma
prof d'anglais
quand elle écrivait à la crème
madame Mermet sans déconner c'était un
truc de ouf je me rappelle elle avait
une Renault neuf frère blanche elle
partait même les voitures dans la
voiture sur la tête bien sûr mais
attends
et tout pour les bien sûr moi j'avais
une prof on était hyper copain c'était
ma voisine madame funching
prof de français on était comme ça on
était hyper copain j'allais toute la
journée chez elle genre il y avait des
élèves y passer
sur ma vie déposé tu disais madame
funching
[Applaudissements]
on allait au théâtre ensemble vous allez
au théâtre
[Rires]
j'appelle ma mère ma mère
j'appelle ma daronne
ma mère ma mère elle parle à personne
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'elle a d'autre à faire que
de me regarder allô
[Applaudissements]
ouais moi je suis à l'antenne là
allô
rajouter de fou
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu peux dire à Kelly que je suis pas un
mytho
[Applaudissements]
de l'oignon et voilà
tout va
va bien
ah il y a Bernard Montiel je lui demande
déjeuner il veut payer elle a plus
d'oseille en plus
elle a acheté le cadeau d'anniversaire
de Bianca en avance là ce weekend elle
est raide c'est moi qui m'invite
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
un cadeau pour toi
excuse-moi tu pourrais prêter 500000 à
cassette
[Applaudissements]